and the News Gazette in Champaign
Illinois reports on a teacher who took
down a gunman inside a high school
police say Angela McQueen tackled the
student happily opened fire yesterday it
happened in the cafeteria at Mattoon
high school a 16 year old student was
shot and later released from the
hospital
the suspect is in police custody police
say McQueen's quick response saved lives
turning to couple is outside Mattoon
high school in central Illinois with how
the attack unfolded Tony good morning
good morning as students make their way
back to school this morning they're
gonna find their classrooms and their
belongings almost exactly as they left
them when shots rang out and this entire
building was evacuated now police are
not identifying the shooter saying he's
a minor but they did say he acted alone
and this could have been much much worse
more than 100 police officers raced with
the chaos at Mattoon high school just
after 11:30 a.m. on Wednesday students
and faculty running for safety reported
a shooter in the school's cafeteria it
was one of the scariest things that
could happen Brayton Davis was one of
the students in the cafeteria when
another student opened fire his knuckles
were grazed in the shooting that's when
I looked left and I saw the person
holding the gun and then they fired
three to five more shots a second
student was struck by as many as two
gunshots but survived Mattoon Police
Chief Jeff Branson credits a teacher now
identified as Angela McQueen with
tackling the shooter that teacher had
not responded as quickly as they had I
think the situation would have been a
lot different alexis perry saw the
confrontation on 4th he's got his finger
on the trigger and it was flying up and
it was hitting the ceiling and immortan
watched as mcqueen continued checking on
others even after overwhelming the
shooter she was walking around and
making sure everything was okay and I
went up and gave her a hug and thanked
her because she could that could have
been a lot worse than she made it to
it wasn't well there is a scary
undercurrent that we should add here and
that is that this is reportedly
the fifth shooting at a central Illinois
High School in just the past four weeks
nor important to remember that very
important to remember Tony thank you so
much